so but what I learned from this was this
friend came forward made this whole
video about me damn fake and from her
point of view she thinks that maybe my
opinions are fake okay and that this
just changed all of a sudden but
remember before the internet we had
different types of relationships you
could talk you could know someone for
years for years and you wouldn't know if
they're conservative if they're Democrat
like what their opinions are on certain
things now it becomes unfortunate as a
content creator because the bigger you
get the more you share and the more
people can find opinions that you
disagree with this leads to family and
friends being mad at you for your
opinions now before you still have those
opinions but you just never spoke about
them so